Oh,
truth of the matter is that most people
don't realize that the majority of
people or suffer the first major heart
attack on Monday morning between 8:00 AM
and 9:00 AM,
people getting ready to go to jobs that
they don't lie,
jobs that are making them sick.
What is it that you could love doing
seven days a week that will bring a
smile to your face?
You've got to start saying yes to your
life.
dreams.
Yes to your unfolding future.
Yes to your potential.
You know,
every year I used to say,
this is my year,
but ladies and gentlemen,
one good year won't be enough for me.
How many of you could use a good decade?
Raise your hands,
bleed.
Fantastic.
All right.
Now here's what I want to do.
I want to share with you how you can
begin to make this your decade.
How many of you know within yourself,
if you ask yourself the question,
have I done all that I am capable of
doing or being in living up to my
potential?
How many of you have to really add,
enter?
No,
I have not done all that I can do.
Raise your hands please.
Okay,
very good.
Now,
here's what we know that people don't do
what they know in life,
but what they do is they operate within
the context of the vision they have of
themselves.
So what I want to share with you is how
to begin to get a larger vision of
yourself and how to begin to make this
your decade.
Because in order to do that,
it's going to be very challenging.
It's going to require a lot of work on
your part,
an ongoing process of personal and
professional self mastery,
and it's going to require that you began
to see yourself worthy of the
requirements in terms of effort,
in terms of commitment,
in terms of action,
in terms of preparation or whatever it
is that you need to do in order to take
your life where you want to take it.
So one of the first things I asked you
to do is I want you to look at your life
right now and think about something
that's important to you.
Something that gives your life a sense
of value.
Think about something that you'd like to
have or something that you'd like to
create for you or your family or for
society.
Once you hold this thought in mind,
now,
one of the first things I want you to do
is don't worry about the inner
conversation that you're going to have.
Don't worry about how you're going to do
it.
That's going to come.
You're going to develop a plan of
action.
You will find the way you will become
the kind of person that can attract the
people,
the resources and everything you need in
order to make that become reality.
But I want you to be mindful of your
inner conversation.
I remember once I was sitting in an
audience and Zig Ziglar who I consider
one of the greatest motivational
speakers on the planet.
He was giving a speech and I was out in
the audience and I saw him going back
and forth and within myself.
I said,
I'd like to do that.
I can do that.
And I leaned over to the guy next to me.
I said,
how much do they pay him to do that?
And he said,
$5,000.
I said,
I know I can do that.
And I admired him.
And then on the way when I was driving
from Tampa,
Florida back to Miami for my inner
conversation kicked in and it said,
Les Brown,
you can't do that.
You don't have a college education.
Les Brown,
you can't do that.
You don't have the money.
You don't have the contacts.
You've never worked for a major
corporation.
What makes you think that you can make
more in one hour talking then you've
made working for a whole month.
I want to ask you a question.
How many of you ever thought about
something you wanted to do and you talk
you out of it?
Raise your hand please.
That inner conversation,
Ladies and gentlemen,
is the reason that most people take
their greatness,
take their ideas to the graveyard with
them.
You know,
the wealthiest place on the planet of
minister said recently,
it was so true.
It's not the gold mines and the various
areas of the world or the diamond mines.
The wealthiest place on the planet is
the graveyard.
Because in the graveyard we will find
inventions that we never,
ever were exposed to,
ideas,
dreams that never became reality,
hopes and aspirations that were never
acted upon because most people allow
that inner conversation for whatever
reason,
the keep them from ever pursuing their
goals.
So let us begin to look at what's
required in order to to make this our
decade.
Why is it that most people don't ever
reach their goals or live up to their
true potential?
One is fear
and there are only two kinds of fears
that we're born with the fear of falling
and the fear of a loud sound.
All of the fears we learn like the fear
of failure.
The next is the fear of success.
As one of the major challenges I had to
deal with,
I was working on a major project and
after it began to grow and it was
extremely successful,
I panicked and I walked away from and
then gave it to someone else because I
didn't believe that I could handle it.
The other thing that keeps most people
from reaching their goals so that a lot
of people become comfortable,
they stop growing,
they stop wanting anything,
they become satisfied,
they stop looking at ways in which they
can improve themselves.
They stopped putting things in front of
them.
I was reading something by a great man,
George Bernard Shaw,
and he said something to the effect that
to have succeeded as to have finished
ones business on earth,
like the male spider who was killed by
the female spider.
The moment he has succeeded in his
courtship and he's.
It goes on to say I like a state of
continual becoming with a goal in front
and not behind.
I remember after giving a speech at a
major corporation,
a gentleman came up to me,
he was up in years and he said,
you know,
that's real great motivation for you
young guys,
but I've done all my work is nothing
else for me to do.
I said,
Oh yes,
you've got a lot to give.
You have a lot to offer.
The fact that still here means that your
business is not through yet.
The other thing that keeps us from
reaching our goal is not feeling worthy.
That's where a lot of people get stuck
because see,
when you don't feel worthy of your goal,
you will begin to unconsciously engage
in self destructive behavior like
procrastinating,
constantly putting things off,
squandering your time and that's what
life is made up.
Something else that keeps us from
reaching our goal and that is many times
because we spend so much time
complaining and blaming everybody or
everything.
I'm reminded of a friend of mine who
talked about the fact that one day he
was walking by this house and some
people sitting on a porch and that was a
dog on the porch and this dog was just
moaning and groaning,
so he was curious and he asked the
honest said,
why is this dog moaning and groaning and
the owners that because he's laying on a
nail,
he said,
well,
why doesn't he get all his is not
hurting bad enough for him to get off?
How many of you know people will moan
and Groan and complain about life all
the time?
Alright.
They might Moan and Groan about that
job.
I'm sick of this job.
I'm sick of you,
and they just Moan and Groan and
complain all the time and never do
anything about it.
They haven't gotten to the point where
they're sick and tired of being sick and
tired.
They just have enough energy to complain
about it and they consider that they in
fact,
they believe that that's equivalent to
doing something about it.
Just complaining.
No,
that can get you where you want to go.
That cannot create your reality for you.
The other thing that keep most people
from realizing their true greatness and
their true potential circumstances,
their environment.
There are many people who believe
because of where they're born because of
the area where they are in life and
where they find themselves.
That's all they know.
Given my circumstances,
ladies and gentlemen,
I shouldn't be doing what I'm doing
right now.
See,
I know something about you even not
knowing you that you've got greatness
within you.
You have the ability to do things that
you can't even begin to imagine.
You have talents and skills in you that
you haven't even began to reach for yet?
No one could have convinced me,
given my circumstances,
given my background,
that I would be doing what I'm doing
right now.
I was born in Liberty City on the floor
and 62nd street,
my twin brother and me,
when we were six weeks of age,
we were adopted.
When I was in fifth grade,
I was identified as Emr labeled
educable,
mentally retarded and put back from the
fifth grade into the fourth grade and
stayed in that category until I got out
of high school.
I have no college training,
but here's what happened.
I had an intervention in my life,
a man who saw something in me at a time
that I did not see something in myself.
I never forget being in his one day
waiting on a friend of mine who was
there to rehearse for play.
He did not show up and he asked me to go
up to the board and write something on
the board and I said,
I can't do that,
sir.
He said,
why not?
I said,
well,
I'm.
I'm in a special education class.
He said,
what do you mean?
I said,
go up to the board and write what I'm
about to tell you.
I said,
I can't do that,
so why not educable mentally retarded,
and he came from behind his desk.
He said,
don't ever say that again.
Someone's opinion of you does not have
to become your reality,
and that changed my life.
It was Oliver Wendell Holmes who said
that once a person's mind is expanded
with an idea or concept,
it can never be satisfied to going back
to where it was.
So some of you are going to experience a
breakthrough.
Some of you are going to go back and
look at your dreams and brush them off.
Some of you are going to begin to look
at yourself and say,
Hey,
look here.
I know I have not done all that I can do
whatever goal that you have in mind.
I want that to be a goal that will
challenge you.
Something that will make you stretch.
It was osborne who said,
unless you attempt to do something
beyond that which you've already
mastered,
you will never grow.
What is it that you looked at at some
point in time when you decided that you
couldn't do it,
that you talk yourself out of it?
Whatever it is,
bring it back out there,
how you going to do it that will come to
you in due time so you don't get in life
what you want.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you get in life what you are not what
you want,
and see the good news is that we can
always become more by working to develop
ourselves.
So the first process of making this your
decade,
you've got to begin to take a look at
your life and look at where are you
right now?
What are your strengths?
What are your weaknesses?
What gives your life a sense of
fulfillment,
a sense of joy?
What does a full rich life means to you?
What is it that you could love doing
seven days a week that are bringing a
smile to your face?
Think about that and all the areas of
your life,
your professional life,
your personal life,
your family life,
your spiritual life.
What is it that you'd like to have?
Once you begin to determine that,
that takes you to the next step,
and that is once you decide what it is
that you want,
now you've got to decide that you
deserve that.
Repeat after me,
please.
I deserve the best that life has to
offer.
I deserve.
Define my purpose in life.
Shake somebody's hand on your right and
left and say,
fine,
you're perfect.
Do you know by actively pursuing your
purpose,
it could perhaps extend your life,
the number one killer in this country of
all the diseases we have,
heart disease,
that's the number one killer,
and if you asked most people what is it
that that the majority of people have
their first harm tag.
Some people will tell you as a result of
obesity or smoking cigarettes or high
cholesterol or high blood pressure,
and all of those are contributing
factors.
However,
the truth of the matter is that most
people don't realize that the majority
of people suffer the first major heart
attack on Monday morning between 8:00 AM
and 9:00 AM.
People getting ready to go to jobs that
they don't like,
jobs that are making them sick.
You see,
when you're not pursuing your goal,
you are literally committing spiritual
suicide.
When you have some goal out here that
you're stretching for and reaching for,
that takes you out of your comfort zone.
You'll find out some talents and
abilities you have that you didn't know
you have.
I started speaking just to elementary
school kids because I knew they didn't
know what I was talking about and they
gave me all God is that we lack Yo.
Yeah.
Then I graduated up to junior high
school and then the senior high school
and then to various community groups and
church groups and civic associations and
then the colleges and to businesses non
traveling across the country and then
traveling nationally and
internationally,
but I never would have discovered what
I'm able to do right now if I wasn't
willing to take a track chance and
you've got to be willing to do that.
You've got to believe in yourself.
I was doing work for a major corporation
and they were having a major downsizing
because that's another terminology for
major fairings and so the people that
were working there,
they approached them and said,
listen,
you are eligible for early retirement.
We will give you a buyout package of
$300,000 if you take it within this time
frame.
However,
after this timeframe,
when we have the downsizing,
you might be among the people cut and
you will lose all of the benefits that
we're talking about right now and the
most you can get us two weeks severance
pay.
Ladies and gentlemen,
only 50 percent of the people that were
eligible.
Tuck this.
Let me tell you something.
If I'd been there,
I'd have gone to ask for your check.
Less than Marvin told me to get his
Jackie's home with
Mama.
Thank.
I would have taken that money so quick
and I had other people checks less.
Got Your check.
Say Ladies and gentlemen,
life is too short.
Trying to pledge.
Save is too short and unpredictable.
Being miserable.
It's too sharp for that.
Here's the thing,
there's no safe position in life.
Let me tell you why it's a quiet secret
that most people don't realize.
You can't get out of life alive.
You can't get out of life,
so there's no safe position you can in
the bleachers or you could die on the
field.
You might as well come out on the field
at Hamilton.
Thank you.
You want to make this your decade.
You've got to decide to be bold,
so you've got to be bold in life.
You got to take life on.
I remember I was at a major corporation.
I had to give a presentation and there
were two guys sitting across from me and
a guy said to the other fellow,
looking at the last two finalists and
that involved my firm and their firm
said,
listen,
looking at the credentials,
this guy doesn't have any credentials.
We have an advantage here.
We've got two phds between us.
I got up and I went in the bathroom,
start talking to myself.
I said,
let's round.
What do you care about their two phd's?
You have six children
and a mama to take care of.
And I went in that meeting and first of
all,
I went at walking bowl,
looking good,
feeling good and smelling good.
Thank you.
Is that tape?
When we started negotiating and operate
in a spirit of absolute certainty,
I looked at them as if the only reason
that they were born was to give me that
contract.
They survived one out of 9 million
sperms to carry out this transaction.
And I got the contract.
No,
thank you.
Got
Most people go through life trying to
creep.
No,
no,
no.
Trying to be casual about it.
No,
no,
no.
You go for live being casual.
You'll end up a casualty.
No,
you've got to be bold in life.
You've got to take life on.
Now.
Here's something else you must be
positive.
See,
a lot of people,
when things don't happen,
when they wanted,
wanted to happen,
they become negative and they turn out
and stop projecting a lot of negative
energy.
No,
no.
You've got to make a conscious,
deliberate,
determined effort to be positive.
Because see,
when you know within yourself,
things are gonna.
Work out for you.
When you will know within yourself that
some way somehow you're going to make
it,
and this is just some,
these are just some of the hoops you've
got to flip through in order to get
there.
It's okay.
I have a friend who went to get a job
and the people didn't hire me.
He was so negative.
Well to hell with you then.
Oh,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
They just don't have a job that
don't burn your bridges behind.
You know,
talk about the guys,
Mama.
Now here's the last thing.
If you want to reach your goal and have
a competitive edge,
you've got to be hungry.
A lot of people love me to tell this
story.
When I got out of school,
you know,
my first major goal was to buy my mother
a home in my hero in broadcasting was
Paul Harvey and I wanted to become
involved in broadcasting and I love the
disc jockeys that were on the air and I
wanted to become a disc jockey and Mr
Washington said something to me that
I'll never forget who was my mentor in
Highschool.
Repeat this.
Whitney is his quote,
it's better to be prepared
for an opportunity and not have one than
to have an opportunity and not be
prepared.
So I started working to develop my
communication skills and expand my
vocabulary.
I started visualizing myself being a
disc jockey.
I saw myself on there having a talk show
and playing records and people listening
to me.
That was my vision.
That was my dream.
I held that in mind constantly and I
would practice all the time.
Practice makes what?
Absolutely not this,
this,
just dislodge that from your mind.
Practice only makes improvement.
Perfection doesn't exist.
They need to take it out of the
dictionary.
It doesn't.
It doesn't exist.
Practice only makes improvement.
You can always better your best.
You have not done your best work yet as
long as you're here,
you have a chance to transcend yourself.
So don't believe in perfection.
That doesn't exist.
It only makes improvement.
So I would practice,
practice,
practice everyday,
everyday,
everyday.
And finally I went over to this radio
station asking God for job and Mr
Birdwell and I said,
how you doing Sarah?
Like to get a job?
I was working on Miami beach at at the
Fontainebleau hotel at the time,
the Jackie gleason and June Taylor
dancers were famous and my favorite
program on television,
most people would not remember John
Barris for Tipton.
Hi,
my name is Michael Anthony.
I have a check for $1,000,000.
How many of you remember that protocol?
Right?
The millionaire.
That was my favorite program on
television.
If this is my fantasy,
you know,
and every time we would drive from Bondi
beach,
I would fantasize.
Oh,
that's the house where I give him a
million.
I'm my by my mother.
That home over there.
So that's my fantasy.
So I went up to visit butterball and he
said,
you have any radio experience?
I said,
no sir,
you have any background in journalism?
I said,
no sir.
but I could never get experience if you
don't give me the opportunity.
I've been practicing a lot,
sir.
He said,
I'm sorry we don't have any job for you.
I say,
thank you sir.
He didn't know my reasons for being
there.
My reason why I wanted to use radios
have means to earn the money to buy my
mother a home.
I went back to the radio station again.
I say,
how you doing Mr Butterball?
My name is Les Brown.
I know your name.
Didn't I just see you here yesterday?
I said,
yes sir.
I say,
y'all have any jobs here?
Did Not tell you.
I said we didn't have in jail.
Yes sir.
But I thought maybe somebody got fired
or resigned.
I didn't know.
I went the next day.
How are you doing this to butterball?
He said yes,
and I just didn't take it personally.
How you doing?
So you all have any jobs in there?
Not just tell you.
Yesterday and the day before.
We didn't have any work while I thought
maybe somebody died so I didn't know.
I didn't know.
I went the next day,
showed up like nothing was wrong.
Like I saw him for the first time.
How you doing Mr Butterball y'all have
in there.
He said,
why make yourself useful?
Go get me some food.
I said,
yes sir.
See many times when you want more,
you've got to be willing to pay your
dues,
so I became the errand boy.
I went and we'll get their lunch and
their dinner and all kinds of food for
them.
After awhile I would take the food to
them in the control room and I would not
leave until they would ask me to and I'd
watched him working the controls and
I've memorized their hand movements and
pretty soon they would trust me with
their cars to go pick up entertainers
that came into town.
Entertainers like Sam Cooke,
I'm Diana Ross and the supremes,
the four tops and the temptations.
I will drive them all over Miami beach
in the disc jockeys cars.
I didn't have any driver's license,
but I'll drive
like I had.
Finally,
one day I was at the radio station and a
guy by the name of rock was drinking
while he was on there.
It was a Saturday afternoon.
I was the only one there.
None of the other jobs were available
and I was looking at him through the
control room window
saying,
drink rock drink.
Want to get him tomorrow?
If you'd asked me
what is on the phone,
rang was a general manager.
I said,
hello?
He said,
les,
this is Mr Klein.
I said,
I know.
He said rock can't finish his program.
I said,
I know you said when you call one of the
other djs that come in.
I said,
yes sir.
I hung the phone up.
I said,
now he must be thinking I'm crazy.
I called my mom and my girlfriend,
Cassandra.
I said,
y'all come out on the front porch and
turn up the radio.
I'm about to
thank you.
Waited for about 20 minutes not calling
back.
I said,
Mr Cline,
I can't find nobody.
He said,
young boy,
do you not a Segue,
the records?
I said,
yes sir.
He said,
going and don't say nothing.
Hear?
I said,
yes sir.
I couldn't wait to get behind those
controls.
I'll put the headphones on.
I said,
look,
this is me lb triple p,
Les Brown,
Your Platter Playing Papa.
There was none before.
Man.
That will be that after me.
Therefore that makes me the one and only
young and single and love to mingle.
Certified,
bonafide and duplicate.
They qualify,
they'll bring you satisfaction,
a whole lot of action.
Look out baby.
I'm your love man.
I was
great.
Thank
you.
When you are able to have charge of your
destiny,
doesn't.
It gives you a good feel.
You can get you gives you choices.
You can do more things.
Say,
my first major goal was to buy my mother
a home.
I feel like Abraham Lincoln who said all
that I am and all that,
I have a hope to be.
I owe to my mother and I said to my
Mama,
one desk and Mama,
when I become a man,
I'm going to buy your home and you won't
have to go to work every day.
You won't have to work.
You just sit down.
Mama.
She was getting up getting dressed to go
to the m and m cafeteria.
That is now just following her around.
I said,
watch Mama.
One day.
You won't have to leave here to go to
work no more.
It was raining outside.
You won't have to go to work in the
rain.
You just do what you want to do.
Like stay home and fix me.
Sweet potato.
My mom fix it kind of sweet potato pie.
You can't eat with your shoes on.
You have to take your shoes off so you
can wiggle your toes.
But that was my dream.
That was my passion.
I
saw that and that drove me.
That was my reason for being so.
One of the things.
In order to make this your decade,
in order to reach your goals,
you've got to find some reasons that
make you strong.
Some reasons that will make you hang in
there when times get rough because
they're going to get rough.
There's got to be very challenging.
Whenever you decide that you want to
grow,
whenever you decide that you want to go
to another level,
all hell will break,
lose everything that will happen.
The other that can happen will happen,
and at the worst possible moment,
they call it Murphy's law.
See,
whenever you decide that you want to go
to another vibration,
it's like when you get into an airplane,
the first thing they tell you to do is
do what?
Fasten your seatbelt because you're
going to experience some turbulence when
you're going up and some of you are
already experiencing that turbulence.
Don't be frightened by that,
so whenever you decide you want to go to
another level,
you've got to fasten your psychological,
your mental and your spiritual seatbelt
because they're going to be awhile
before you experienced a comfortable
altitude.
You're going to get there.
It's there,
but you've got to go through this phase
here.
This is how you grow.
This is how you develop.
See,
life is like a rollercoaster.
Sometimes you're up,
sometimes you're down.
Sometimes things go well and sometimes
they don't go well,
but in the down moments,
that's when you discover who you are
during the down moments,
in this prosperous time,
you put it in your pocket and the lean
times,
you put it in your hall and that's when
you discover who you are.
Thanks.
Five reasons that empower you.
Why is it that you deserve your goal?
What are the five reasons that you won't
give up when life catch you?
On the blind side,
when the messenger of misery visits you,
what are you going to do?
What will keep you in the game when life
knocked you to the canvas?
See,
the buster douglas that fought in the
last fight was not the buster Douglas,
Mike Tyson.
So the buster douglas that got knocked
down while I'm fighting.
Mike Tyson had gotten out on alcohol
recovery center.
His mother had died.
His wife was ill with a terminal
illness.
He was considered a nothing a bomb.
So when he got knocked down,
buster Douglas had a reason to get back
up because he said,
I'm dedicating this fight to the memory
of my momma,
but when he fought the last fight that
he had and it got knocked down and had a
guaranteed $24,000,000 in his pocket,
they got up.
He just said,
hurry up and count me out.
Thank you.
Why'd you?
Why'd you leave us on somebody to get
hurt?
So you've got to have some reasons that
when life knocks you down,
it's gone.
How long it's going to knock you down
when people disappoint you,
and that's going to happen.
When they been you in,
that's going to happen.
When they lied to you and that's going
to happen.
When they say,
well,
you can count on me and they won't show
up and that's going to happen.
When you're wanting to throw in the
towel and give up yourself and that's
going to happen.
When live collapse on you and catch you
on the blind side,
it drops you to your knees and start
choking you.
You got a dream though I ain't got no
dreams and that's going to happen.
What reason can you remember that you
can call on that you can reach on,
that could make you get back up.
Find that reason.
It was alive and knocked me down.
I said,
life.
I'm doing this because I want to make my
momma proud of me.
I'm doing this because I want my
children to have a better life than what
I have.
I'm doing this because all my life,
I've been told I'll be a loser that I
wouldn't make it all my life.
I've heard people say made me take them
back to the welfare department.
I'm doing this to make them a lot.
I believe like Frank Sinatra,
he said,
the best revenge and life is massive
success.
I'm doing this so I can become massively
successful and what that kind of courage
with that kind of affirmation and reason
to empower me,
I got a saying that when life knocks you
down,
try and land on your back because if you
can look up,
you can get off.
Thank you.
When you run out of money,
when things don't work out for you,
when things happened that you could not
anticipate,
what are the reasons that you can think
of that can keep this strong,
that can keep you in the game,
that will be your rod and staff,
the comfort you that can be your bridge
over troubled waters,
those reasons.
A very important Nietzsche said,
if you know the why for living,
you can endure almost anyhow,
so find out the reasons that you do what
you do.
Find out the reasons that will make you
strong,
that will make you walk by faith and not
by sight.
That will make you pursue your dream
when everybody is against you or don't
believe in you no more,
and let me tell you something that's a
lonely feeling.
It's a lonely feeling,
particularly people that you're doing it
for or people that stand to benefit the
most,
or people who should be the number one
members in the encouragement club,
but they ended up saying you can't do
it,
and they become members of the
discouragement club.
Oh,
it hurts very badly.
I know what that's like.
Have people that you love close to you.
They look at you with that look and say,
why don't you try something else?
Why don't you give up?
I say,
but this is my life.
I have got to do this less.
You had a good job at sears.
Bad Man.
Like you
mama.
I can't go back and see.
I can't.
I can't do.
I got to be my own boss.
I,
I can't do that.
I mean,
you know,
it's,
it's ladies and gentlemen.
You know when you work on a job that's
dead in you,
you can see the ceiling already.
It's like going in the middle of a movie
and after you've seen the movie setting
back through that over again,
there's something
missing.
You know,
the heroes not going to die.
You know what the outcome is already and
so that's why a lot of people,
lady was telling me,
she said when she went to work,
Bob,
like a refrigerator fell on her shoulder
as soon as she stepped in because she
knew she could.
She'd gone as far as she could go see
they're paying or just enough to keep
them from quitting and she's work just
hard enough just to keep from getting
fired.
How many of you know people like that?
Raise your hand,
why you didn't raise your hand you don't
want or
I'll just leave it out.
Just here's something else.
Make a commitment to be happy
so you don't have.
You're laughing a lot,
so life is too short.
Going through and look at,
hopefully tie to Douglas.
Sometimes we take life too seriously.
Oh No.
Make a commitment to be happy.
Find little things just to get tickled
about and laugh.
Find ways to be happy in the moment.
A lot of people say,
well,
I'll be happy when I pay off all my
bills.
Oh,
no,
no.
I'll be happy when I get by divorce.
No,
no.
I'll be happy with the children.
God.
Oh No,
no.
You want to be happy,
and I said,
there are no guarantees.
No one's saying you're going to be here
two,
three or four years from now,
so you want to be happy right now in the
moment.
Repeat after me.
I must make a commitment
to be happy right now,
right now,
all I got.
Take somebody that's had on your right
and left and say,
you deserve to be happy.
Make a commitment to be happy because
life now has new meaning for you.
Just enjoying the sunset or just looking
at life,
looking at nature,
going for a walk.
It's the little things in life that
counts.
Here's something else that you want to
begin to do in order to make this your
decade.
He want to began to get all the toxic
people out of your life.
How?
Hello
Energy drainers,
get them out of your life.
See,
ladies and gentlemen,
it takes a lot of energy to reach your
goal.
It takes a lot of emotional,
mental,
and spiritual energy to reach our goal,
and you can run faster with a 100 will
want to go then with one around your
neck.
So there are two kinds of relationships.
It's Simon talks about this nourishing
relationships and toxic relationships,
nourishing relationships,
all the relationships that inspire you,
they motivate you,
they bring the best out of you.
Toxic relationships or relationships
with people that always criticize you.
All they can do is find fought.
All they can do is just explore your
weaknesses.
All they can do is remind you of the
mistakes that you've made in the past.
These people are bad for your health.
Toxic people can run your blood pressure
up.
One applicant spoils the whole barrel.
One negative inner greater energy
drainer can spa your whole life.
I know people lives have been ruined
because somebody wasn't good for them.
See,
there are some people that aren't good
for you.
Hello,
they aren't good for you.
Got To get them out of your life.
See,
a lot of people put up with a lot of
foolishness because they don't want to
die by themselves.
Here's what I believe.
I believe in a one to a box theory.
Thank you.
Question
of yourself.
Make a list of who you communicate with
most and ask yourself the question,
what kind of person am I becoming
because of this relationship?
Is it helping me to grow mentally and
emotionally and spiritually?
Am I becoming a better person because of
this relationship?
Do they bring out the best in me?
They'll do.
They inspire me.
They encouraged me to develop my
greatness.
Do they make me stretch?
So you got to look at the people in your
life and find out what kind of person
are you becoming?
Because of that relationship my mother
used to say,
birds of a feather flock together.
You run around with losers.
You will end up a loser.
Unconsciously,
unconsciously you will pick up their
wage.
You'll pick up their habits.
You'll pick up,
most importantly,
their attitude about life.
If you around cynical,
negative people all the time,
you will become cynical and negative.
So you gotta watch yourself.
Many of us are living out the lives of
other people,
living out their conclusions,
living out of their consciousness.
The other thing is that you begin to
look at looking at your life and looking
at what it is that you want to achieve.
Another crucial thing that you must do
is align yourself with powerful people.
Align yourself with people that can
encourage you,
people that can empower you,
people that you can learn from,
people that you can grow from.
That's very important,
so if you have people around you that
can contribute to your growth.
When I wanted to become a speaker,
I joined the National Speakers
Association.
I wanted to be around the Dr Norman
Vincent Peale's,
the Zig Ziglars,
the Dwayne dyers.
This.
I wanted to be around people that were
doing what I wanted to do.
I want to learn from them,
and you want to do that too.
You want to align yourself with people
who think like you,
people who dream like you,
people who want more out of life,
people that are stretching and searching
and seeking some higher ground in life
as opposed to the majority of people.
Somebody said,
always strive to get on top and life
because it's the bottom that's
overcrowded and so you don't want to be
on the bottom.
See,
it's easy to be on the bottom.
It doesn't take any effort to be a
loser.
It doesn't take any motivation and
didn't drive in order to stay down there
on a low level,
but it calls on everything in you.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you have to harness your will to say,
I'm going to challenge myself.
Sometimes I have to pull myself out of
bed to come on.
Less things I know I shouldn't do.
I don't do things I shouldn't do.
I do.
I found that the biggest enemy you have
to deal with is yourself.
There's an old African proverb that
says,
if there's no enemy within the enemy
outside can do us no harm.
So think about that.
Thank you.
You
begin to look toward making this.
Your decade as you begin to look toward
making your life different,
he'll begin to look at yourself.
You've got to redefine yourself.
Who are you right now and who must you
become in order to create what you want?
What else has changed about you?
What is it that you're doing right now
that would be a liability for you as you
begin to look toward the future and take
inventory of yourself?
What is it about you right now that
you've got to leave this behind because
this no longer fits looking at where you
want to go and the kind of person that
you must become,
the kind of standards that you have for
you.
What is it that you must do differently?
Repeat after to me please.
If you want to keep on getting what
you're getting.
Keep on doing what you're doing
so that doesn't take an Einstein for
that.
It makes sense unless you change your
pattern,
unless you change the way you're
thinking,
unless you change your behavior,
you're going to continue to produce the
results in your life.
See,
all of us are winters,
but some of us are producing results
that we don't want and so all you have
to look at your game plan.
Look at your strategy.
How is it that you have been been?
What is it that you've been doing to
produce this so you have a director,
you're the producer,
you're writing the script,
you're the star of your life,
and as you begin to look at your life,
you can decide whether or not it's a
smash and whether or not it's a flop
that's in your hands.
Look at your life,
look at where you want to go.
Don't worry about your circumstances.
Don't worry about your age.
Have a friend who was up in age,
over 70 and she wanted to build a
multimillion dollar complex name is Dr
Johnny Coleman Lenders and bankers say,
you can't do that.
You're too old.
She ignored them.
That building now stands ladies and
gentlemen on long time,
million dollar structure,
but are a lot of people who would have
listened to that,
that a lot of people that would not have
even gotten to that point,
they were to talk themselves out of even
going down to the bank to ask for it
because they've already said no to
themselves.
See,
it's time now.
If you want to make this your decade,
you've got to start saying yes to your
life.
You've got to start saying yes to your
dreams,
yes to your unfolding future,
yes to your potential as opposed to say,
no.
C,
87 percent of our self talk is negative.
So you've got to make a conscious,
deliberate,
determined effort to say yes to your
dreams.
Why not?
Why not me?
Don't spend time like most people going
through life complaining.
Don't try and get on talk shows and tell
everybody how life has done you.
Here's what's happening in the audience.
Eighty percent don't care.
And 50 percent.
Gladys,
you
alright?
So,
so when you know that you all go wrong,
what they did to get away from me before
they come back,
thanks.
Ramana said something very important.
He said,
hey,
it doesn't matter what happens to you.
The only thing matters.
What are you going to do about it?
That's all that matters.
Okay?
Life knocked you down.
What do you do about how long are you
going to sit there and say,
you know what that did to me?
Who was the head I racquet.
Use that energy to get up
from and move on and get on with your
life.
You got to learn to let the past go so
you can grow.
Many people never act on their dreams
because they allow their past
experiences to determine what their
possibilities are.
Whatever you've done in the past that's
not a reflection of your possibilities.
That's just a reflection of your
consciousness.
development and your growth.
The future is unfolding for you right
now.
The future is unlimited for you right
No one knows where you can go.
No one knows what you are,
what you're capable of lava,
what's possible for you.
You don't even know that.
I had no idea.
Ladies and gentlemen,
no one could have convinced me that I
was able to do this.
I never forget.
I was speaking in Detroit in a high
school friend of mine saw me afterwards
and he was backstage.
He said,
I can't believe it's the same person,
and I thought for a moment and I said,
it's not the person you know you go,
he doesn't live here anymore.
We have the
power to change our personal history,
changing the direction of our lives,
changing our thoughts,
changing where we want to go,
exploring new horizons.
So as you began to look at this decade
and affirming that this is your decade
as you set goals that will make you
stretch,
that will bring out the best in you as
you begin to remove the negative toxic
people from your life as you decide to
take some chances in life.
And that's one of the things that's very
important.
This God said,
if you're not willing to risk,
you cannot grow and if you cannot grow,
you cannot become your best.
And if you cannot become your best,
you cannot be happy.
And if you can't be happy and what else
is there?
I'll never forget.
When I reached my first major goal of
buying my mother left home,
I never forget what it was like.
And you're going to have this experience
when you reach some major goal.
When I drove up to the house and I got
out and I gave mom a key and I said,
Mama,
this is for you.
I'll never forget the look on her face.
She said.
She said,
well my God,
no one could have convinced me when I
adopted you off that this would happen.
She's so thank you.
She said,
you
me so many damn problem.
Yeah,
that's what I was given.
Had a lot of energy,
but no one knew what I was going to
become.
It was a great philosopher,
Gerta.
He says,
look at a man the way that he is,
he only becomes worse,
but look at him as if he were what he
could be.
Then it becomes what he should be.
And what Mr Washington did was he looked
beyond my faults and saw my needs and he
said,
I see something in you.
And I was there.
Oh God,
I hope he's right and I want to live up
to his expectations.
He no one rises to low expectations.
Finally,
here's one last thing I like to leave
with you going to make this your decade,
find some cause that you believe in,
so this is my profession,
but my greatest joy in life is working
with young kids.
Every Monday I fly up to Chicago to work
with 600 young kids and Christ Universal
Temple Church,
working with them to develop a sense of
purpose and direction.
With alliance,
we've developed a training program.
If they're addicted to drugs or alcohol,
we help them to get into a permanent
recovery program.
If they're not,
we help them to develop a vision of
themselves where drugs and alcohol does
not fit.
I love it when I go into the Cook County
jail and see the look on these young men
faces that anger and the self hatred and
then when we leave there,
see the difference in them as we begin
to touch a spark in them as Mr
Washington touched in me and there's no.
You cannot put a dollar price on that.
That's my reason for being.
What is it that you would like to give
the planet?
What is it that you'd like to leave
here?
See,
someone paid a price for us to be here.
I believe that we live in the greatest
country in the world that gives us an
opportunity to make a difference in
life.
We are blessed to have been dropped off
on this part of the planet.
A friend of mine was in Manila and saw a
bumper sticker say Yankee,
go home and take me with you.
So as you began to look at your life,
decide what kind of legacy do I want to
lead?
What kind of statement do you want to
make with your life?
What three things you want said when you
die,
what contribution do you want to make?
I don't know what you want to do.
I don't know what you want to achieve
with your life.
Here's what I know about you and about
you and about you and about you.
That you have greatness within you,
that you have things and gifts and
talents that you've been bestowed with
that as you work consciously making a
conscious,
deliberate,
determined effort to cultivate and bring
them out and develop a sense of purpose
and knowing that your life can make a
difference and decided to make and leave
a legacy with your life.
I say to you that the planet will never
be the same again because you showed up
as you begin to look toward the future
and affirmed that this is your decade.
This is what I like to leave with you,
that I'm known by.
It's become my motto and it says simply
this,
what are you want to do?
My goal is to be the best son that I can
beat up my mother.
My goal is to be the best father that I
can be to my children and my goal is to
create a drug free America.
Be the best motivator that I can be.
Whatever your goal is,
this is what I like to leave with you
says simply this,
that if you want a thing bad enough to
go out and fight for it to work day and
night,
for it to give up your time,
your peace,
and your sleep for it.
If all that you dream and scheme is
about it and life seems useless and
worthless without it,
and if you'd gladly sweat for it and
fret for it and plan for it and lose all
your terror of the opposition for it,
and if you simply go after this thing
that you want with all of your capacity,
strengthen sagacity,
faith,
hope and confidence and stern
pertinacity.
If neither cold poverty,
famish or go sickness or pain of body
and brain can keep you away from the
thing that you want.
If dogged and grim you besiege and
visited with the help of God,
you'll get it.
This is Mrs Mamie Brown's baby boy,
Leslie Calvin Brown saying it's been a
plum pleasing pleasure.
Thank you.